like did you know that Jenna Ortega
choreographed her own dancing for
episode four Wednesday yeah that same
dance that would later go viral being
recreated by artists like Lady Gaga and
how did Jenna prepare for it I watched
videos of goth clubs in the 80s I
watched Susie and the Banshees because
she was a reference maid Jenna took
heavy influence from the Susie and the
Banshees music video fun house I feel
kind of bad because I kind of I ripped
off a couple of her moves Jenna
unknowingly had covid while filming the
scene which made her a little surprised
to see it blow up online it was awful to
film and I asked to redo it but we
didn't have time apparently she woke up
feeling sick and they had to keep giving
her medicine between takes on set